This transformation has actually reduced the amount of parallelism.
Previously, we had P-squared threads per tile and P-squared way parallelism within a tile.
Now we only have P threads per tile, so we have less parallelism than we did before.
Well does that matter? Well, if we have a big, big N body problem to solve, it probably doesn't matter.
For a big, big problem there's probably so much parallel work
that will easily fill the machine, even with our new version,
but if we have a more modest-sized problem,
the lesser amount of parallelism might mean this method isn't the best,
because we might reduce the amount of parallelism to the point where we can't keep the whole GPU busy.
The big picture by what we've done here is that we've chosen an implementation that has fewer threads
and does more work per thread.
You'll often see this technique when you can convert communication between threads,
which is correspondingly more expensive to communication within a thread,
because communication between thread local storage
is faster than communication between threads within shared memory.